this is a buy yesterday and now you're
listening to the dolt this is a
bi-lingual American history podcast each
week I read a story from American
history in Spanish and English to my
friend Gareth Reynolds who has no idea
what the topic is going to be about and
I don't think that's true don't really
finish no I don't think that's correct
that's never happened and it's a
bi-weekly - okay well I guess man is
accurate hola all right that'll that's
quite enough amigo shut up
Silencio megusta basketball sure si
absolutely what feels one of those words
you can just add a no-entry is that most
of my Spanish and I get close with most
of them like yeah and we have a guest
today oh wait we're doing special of a
special episode because our friend Ari
Shaffir has a Netflix special coming out
right now it's out today right it's out
max out today and the exact date that
it's out just to be clear allow you to
July 18 today that is today and it's
going to be different because today Ari
is going to read us a story from
American history
hey and we're going to learn from Ari I
got you prepared I did some research I
really believe it yeah you have a
computer yeah I got it so half of you
guys yeah so I went nice and dark well
either way okay I have to do the story
of Levi Strauss okay that's a gene okay
or um the BTK killer we get to choose
yeah I mean I prepared both of them oh
wow or from memory I realize on the way
in I can vividly describe the block
Dalia Dalia Dippolito who also tried to
have her husband killed
did she really uh it was great they
caught on camera was great but like
Dalia yeah no I'm gonna be named
everything there's an original block
Dalia and this was like at 1900 like a
coke - yeah like a gritty reboot over a
lady got cut in half
mm-hmm it's like a gritty reboot right
yeah
pretty bird video yeah
but reboot is the operative word I would
say levi-strauss yeah you Levi Strauss
yeah I'm not great about the Jews I know
the other ones okay Levi Strauss I don't
know anything about except I like I like
to put myself in those [ __ ] pants
yeah they're great
I'm warming up his hand yeah like the
Crushers I did mr. Miyagi over here fair
to say one thing about the BTK killer
yes I'll let it to the police his return
address was Bill Thomas Gilman I mean
that's a giveaway yeah Wow
well where's your mentally like your
head is in a weird place like a return
address a Killman murderer uh it's on
Netflix your special on Netflix called
double negative speaking of Killman see
you guys there yeah I don't think
anybody knows what does that mean
because he's killing yeah okay all right
sure I mean that I'm stoned at lady Foot
nockard Locker now it was so good
how great would it be to do is fill a
flat like Evelyn so what about Bennifer
so with the film in play
no what's build a lady philosopher many
when someone's thinking about Foot
Locker to go lady for us yeah so yeah
that really is true even if you got the
footlocker not a lot of people be like
you know what would you close out to the
public or we just have to deal with
people shopping perhaps and I think you
keeping up a tough one I think you're
shopping for sure no it's something it's
border to joke they're like oh I can use
it you don't want to Hollywood out you
know let it be real could you wear those
striped shirts
yeah oh yeah so there was a lady
footlocker two lockers
it's regulation I'd wear the outfit you
were yeah right and if people are
questions I'd help them right good just
come in excuse me or do some socks with
a pump oh yeah of course I'll get back
to Facebook in a minute if you look over
there talk to bread but I think that was
pretty great do an audience out of the
wall okay I'll pay for it all right so
the Killman the BTK killer door without
levi-strauss so tell me why Strauss
Strauss in it okay Sam disco boy yes the
um Cisco born in Germany Oh Sherman Jew
yeah that way before
he was he got out before the stuff
happened swear yeah I don't think he saw
coming rumor alleged right yeah we still
haven't seen pictures or anything yeah
like over conduct look I uh exam I'll
wait all my way for the book to come out
well those were doctored exaggerated the
killer anyway
German Jew Levi Strauss port 1826 okay
um in North of Bavaria okay where BMW is
later invented sure yeah you see not as
sure about that that doesn't seem like
stating no no it's more you question
your own sentence yeah I realize now
it's definitely later invented 1826 of
the pre car right yeah yeah free car
1826 day definitely workers are more of
a horse situation at that point paying
that did the horse BMW didn't have a
builder before that I know look at the
engineering he's unbelievable is ahead
yeah it's a bottom part yeah it's got
one horsepower look can he hit one off
power or you start embellishing three
horsepower this one horse he was named
Loeb Strauss but he was born because of
his ear left lobe l OE B is note is that
a common name and not in Judaism that I
know of my own a German common name loud
okay all right I wish it was L OBE
lobe would be used here Yeah right my
parents were laid hello Eadie mm-hmm
feels like we're getting close to
something that bloob bloob you leave
your truck yeah his dad died of
tuberculosis to do 17 had almost
everybody yeah almost everybody back man
just a normal right
TB takes to keep you killer yeah it took
up 90% of people or something I don't
have the exact figures kinda coughing
mmm
that's what pink off cuz it also to be
TVs got a cop - no I got a I am more
mild economy from what I know you've had
to watching much more than it was in the
movie uh we're uh okay crown tombstone
Tim stone oh yeah that's what I mostly
take my TB facts from
and he caught he coughed a bit but it's
more like I'm coughing up blood cough oh
that doesn't say that sounds minor like
you're like you're like a drowning cough
I picture like a Dave Attell cough who's
talking about walls of phlegm coming
down that's good as a chronic cough yeah
man it's you gotta stop smoking man why
I'm good all two years later him mom
Rebecca at him they moved to America to
join his older brothers we were there in
New York okay
they were established who established it
a dry goods store [ __ ] yeah okay so
don't drive should I share yeah let's
try it stuff it's dry supposed to a wet
goods store yeah what we check they went
out of business a lot of the whitetips
boys are pretty recently hosing [ __ ] oh
yeah yeah okay I guess yeah that was
1948 by 1950 he became an expert in the
dry goods and salesmanship business with
a two years in 1558 1918 fifth okay so
okay two years so he merely he really
figured out dry goods within two years
for sure man that's just a normal Jewish
thing and expert we're experts at
[ __ ] salesmanship yep and it
excelling a thing the heel or these are
so dry you're gonna love these how so
what is it dry essentially a dry good is
I think you're I mean are we talking
about dried foods no no I think it means
like Goods good okay
yeah like canvases and like my chairs
okay we of parts well the idea that
anyone would be selling wet chairs
well wouldn't you just call it a stuff
stored or maybe store store yeah we had
invested shortening back then right yeah
they had a roof so we're like we're dry
goods I'm going to talk to the shelves
company about how much yeah yeah what
was exactly that yeah comes in with a
bunch of peaches where do I put these
get out of here
[Laughter]
and then a huge moment in American
history happened when they discovered
gold in Kelo that was a big deal sure
yeah yeah yeah
gold gold they called it gold gold well
yeah they were responsible losers
probably hilsa okay right okay gold gold
so the old gold rush rush yeah yeah and
yeah and he he became an American
citizen okay one month later moved out
to California okay so everybody was
doing yeah he wasn't trying to mine for
gold
he was just like delicacies like this
gentleman details yeah I think
everyone's going there so I can go out
there and maybe start dry goods store
yeah exactly he was like I'm gonna die
I'm gonna sell stuff to these gold
miners yeah his hands dirty really sure
the guys who made all the money back
then it wasn't the gold miners as people
selling [ __ ] to the global yeah yeah
and apparently ever the price was jacked
up over the mountains you could be
anything so the price like five times
higher over there so you're doing for
everything for everything okay wet goods
dry goods all of it all the goods all
the milk at lukewarm goods hot goods hot
goods called Goods wet goods dragons
prostitution when prostitution dry
prostitution suits cost more out there
because it's harder to get him there uh
well yeah supplying there's a alright
yeah yeah I was in China once I went
into the Great Wall of China sure enough
that is there right but is okay so far I
thought of no no access man hold on I
know there it is we already today okay
and I thought it on that one anyway this
is bottle of water this guy's telling
let's say for a dollar usually sold for
who saw him two three right that's what
he sell a tourist let's say yeah cuz
yeah and but it was like in whatever the
yen was and uh I was I stuck that no way
it's [ __ ] one you trying to rob me
like always and um because I'm white you
know that's Armel yeah but he was like
Yemen it's one if you don't to lug up a
case of water up to the [ __ ] Great
Wall of China okay I guess keep a change
you're terrific
these are white goods right so I assume
the the prostitutes probably cost more
there okay yeah yeah oh yeah I had quite
a luxurious life with all those clean
gold miners coming after them yeah the
webinar which listed dreamers yeah so he
moved he moved at February 1853 and
right that all the
cuz of his brother stops we don't know
what happened to the other out happen
Jabra game else nobody heard about
nobody yeah and when he's rich and
famous no one's like what happened at
Billy Jay never sent for them nothing no
one knows sweat it's [ __ ] up I wonder
if they even knew that he was Levi
Strauss or that he started the company
he did he was still there waitin to
leave our but he hasn't changed his name
to lead it oh yeah it's another thing uh
I became an expert in trade he was like
you know what [ __ ] this Loeb [ __ ]
he went to Levi I'm leaves weird I'm
Levi yeah I think if you want to sound
so German maybe or yeah I think we all
after that that's still a thing
yeah exists in a world war one is coming
in 45 years
Philip yeah he for some sense yeah yeah
yeah
the dry war yeah that was a dry war um
price was gouged price was gouged for
everything but he's selling everything
now right he's got a whole she selling
everything
no I went he's having trouble Oh trouble
we can make a lot of money on the stuff
he is selling but he's having trouble so
he is gauging okay which is a normal
Jewish like sure you can say it I can't
synthetic Lee I guess mostly Belgian
we're not going to disagree with you but
we can't say okay man oh my god
and it was all going in there so it's
like he was far before I go we care but
he's having trouble on one occasion he
couldn't even sell a piece of canvas
okay the one hotel piece of canvas he
couldn't sell it well you have a white
for making tents what oh yeah I thought
he was trying to hit any art demographic
I thought he was like when no one wants
to paint here come on in an art scene
beautiful it is the gallery the
gold-mining town is lacking in museums
the dreamer on the hill yeah but when
they're not gold-mining how will they
blow up Steve yeah what will they look
at look at this painting for an escape
yeah
so no none of that was for making tents
maybe he was trying to sell it for - hi
cuz everyone needed a tent
beauty here might be right you might be
right he might have gouged you might
have over Galax right he Jie the slip
slip of gouging yeah
you gotta take it to them to the people
who have go hey you guys got gold no
moving on
hey you guys heard yeah hey you want a
10 I'm gouging I mean wanna ten for the
price of whatever you have in your
pocket you should
dude I guess how to sell glass because
you got it down
you should also name glasses you should
teach a name how to sell glasses
yeah I got that one okay I don't know
yeah really great at me I'd probably do
what the chocolate yeah nail that one I
mean how could it not go back
how much money you have in your wallet
$14 I got something for 40 nose right
here shocking you should say that number
sir
what what a coincidence again okay
anyway I couldn't sell it so he just
gave it to a give it to a tailor he gave
the canvas to attend gimme came over to
her okay he loaned it to him yeah story
hello you knew okay who transformed it
this is a huge moment - 10 pairs of
trousers ten yeah did he know that the
guy was gonna do this there was a guy
like was he like you know what yeah hey
you know what Larry do your magic you do
you not to get in the way of your art
form I know you I know I'm sorry
something here that I don't see we're
coming back after like all right man I'm
gonna need that killeth the far these
are pants what the [ __ ] did you do oh my
god
Michelangelo had a block of stone he saw
gave it inside of it that's right oh and
major on this guy's his other artist at
all pay up soldiers yeah on exit right
it was rough canvas pictures those must
have been nice - where - on those hot
days
Coco clear gold well canvas chase your
inner thighs that I died I don't know
what color the canvas was I don't think
I don't think at any time back down
they're like oh these pants are too
rough they were just like oh and uh
suede pants like there is there is no
except for the really rich guy I was
just cruising around silk pants everyone
else is like I just want pants swim to
cover my legs yeah I probably go for the
Donald Duck look then what bottomless
you know shirt up top little boat oh
yeah then just shoes and socks nothing
down low especially we've got no dick
yeah you look the foam is not that's one
thing you're forgetting he doesn't have
it ya know
yeah
that out although I heard they're doing
a gritty reboot you guys want to see my
dry goods yeah have you guys ever seen
the director's cut of chicken run no
graphic sexy is that right graphic well
I know the original title is chicken
[ __ ] okay that's why they changed it
yeah I got to be honest in this my
videos right how you take they'll let
you put it on the DVD extras there's a
lot of anal to show the penetration tool
and say that a lot but it's difficult to
watch it's of course a for sure long
it's long did their long read to the cat
but with chickens anyway
pants sold easily excuse me trouser
easily sure the case almost like well
let me say our thick it's like being in
a tent but it's just my bottoms for my
leg it's like putting my dick in a tent
yeah so we started making these [ __ ]
pants out of ten canvas okay okay he's
clean it up so he now he's just buying
tent canvas and cranking out pan clay
not he knew how to be a Salesman had it
figure it out when this guy's doing it
this guy's making him and then he's
paying the guy while he playing the guy
it was a tailor he might have also been
a Jew yeah say they knew each other
right he's at least paying him for his
time but maybe he's working for a pairs
of pants every 10 you know you guys
don't seem on board with my theory no I
wouldn't do it if I was a guy who made
pants I wouldn't be like that's a great
idea you'll give me pants yeah I can
already make type G I can make fabric
you made the guy sound like an idiot in
my head oh yeah take a pair of pants
yeah not just some idiot is like boy
pants hey lobe laid eye I saw head leave
our um maybe a return for this money we
throw in a pair of pimps I say I don't
know love
don't call me lo that's my father call
network Emmet local spicy coughed up
along with TB
he had that wider room stone cough maybe
fall off a horse someone catches you
wait let's go ahead that's what happens
okay the original cut out a yoke behind
it I don't know what that means
wait Els yeah the original cut of his
pants was jazzy other yokes behind it
which made it so you didn't have to wear
it with a waist belt
a yoke okay so that may have been like
it over the time yeah it is the grinder
II situation yeah but attached to the
pants okay so he had hey no no waist
belt necessary which also it proves our
point there not a short in those days to
just built right or is a yoke something
like pull and tighten could be maybe up
to the shirts like hold like it goes up
for your shirt as you pull it down which
pulls the pants up okay it's sort of
like you're really a flag but they're
your hands until ears or some right now
right now we're way off on so many ships
a helmet dreaming yeah so it was
screaming at their phone in their car
subtalar I want to okay what happened
along great way love what is the yoke
okay so we had yoke pants I think
Aaron's looking at what yoke is are you
earned or you just told you right now
sorry Aaron skyping you got me good for
it but I'm not seeing it okay it's also
something in an egg oh that you know
that I don't know yeah yoke of centered
of this yeah yeah big in the eye right
yeah they separate the two parts of it
you know the clear part mode I go let
the baby yellow the baby oh yeah okay
that is also yolk that's a penny where
your rose that's good to know
baby yellow yeah this feels like one of
your juice stories oh yeah I know that
jewel if you crack an egg if there is
one little drop of blood in it like if
you see a special driver blood not
kosher that's all that I got it's not
kosher not kosher and it's because it
was like fertilized and then it's no
longer like just so I can non fertilized
egg it's a piece of an animal uh-uh
oh yeah cuz you can't mix my code no you
can't mix anything right like the I know
are you gonna actually you can't do it's
just cheese you can do and cheese and
meat yeah okay to get milk come here but
anyway also if you crack three eggs into
a bowl and they're all good crack a
fourth one one double blood all of them
alright that's it give to the going give
its the [ __ ] still eat it so eat
anything we share will but I'm not I'm
not sure I appreciate this believe it
he's chickens don't hang upside down
where you killed off going to the my
keys of religion Ellie anything yeah
yeah we're a rule where if you find this
is like an actual case in the Talmud
where if you find a piece of meat on the
ground outside which happens a lot
outside of a street with ten restaurants
on it okay and nine of the more kosher
ones not are you allowed to eat that
piece of meat well say no oh Road bacon
anyway yeah that was my question or are
you Candace
this place isn't kosher well also it's
on hair yeah
so yes yeah I need it you can't eat it
yeah okay I don't think I've ruled
you've ruled on it I'm not part of a
kosher committee Oh judge coach coach
yeah yeah okay for sure
Brooke David okay so they have yoga
pants yeah okay it's possible also to
put working tools in them and samples of
gold in these in these superimposed
pockets they put on superimposed like
outside oh okay I'm sorry right okay
sort of like your panting okay yeah you
know how the stuff determines that out
you can see the pants like how do you
wear your jeans and back to the future -
it's accurate truck so later he replaced
the canvas with denim okay maybe like
whatever and then that's it
who do we know why we don't know why all
the researchers did don't know what we
do know why he dyed it blue okay it's
obvious according to most places they
always say it's obvious because you can
hide in the ocean no indigo is the
cheapest die really yeah okay what do
you say I don't say so that's why not
your jeans are blue for I'm wearing blue
jeans and you're wearing grey don't okay
there's no need to go I'm bad inside
pockets oi I think it's trying to judge
judge judge colour says now judge cold
again I found like the yoke mean Oh what
okay
it's instead of your your pants being at
the waist being straight
you're like slightly curved up on both
sides oh that's in now it's more for a
woman give what is how is that oh my god
I'm so sorry
how getting emotional Aries emotional
how is that a thing that why would that
make any
yeah why don't I make it easier we just
fall from higher it looks like it it
looks like it hangs on easier without a
belt oh really
yeah Dave Anthony you're questioning
eyes will stop you from coming a
millionaire in the 1850 just be buying
the pants that make it up Dave we don't
need a yoke get that Luger out of here
come to the goldmine its pants are down
again okay John what I'm trying to say I
want to dry good stories oh okay yeah
what is it dry good say yeah okay so in
in the United States dry goods are
products such as textiles ready-to-wear
clothing and sundries sundry okay I'd
like to think consumer goods that are
distinct from those carried by a
hardware and grocery store so there the
ship is not in a hardware store that is
dry the [ __ ] that's not in a hardware
store at a grocery strive we don't have
the market we've got a niche if you want
a Hechinger since I still grocery stores
are closed action sorry talking
packagers like lumber that's still
around
I don't believe okay well I don't in
1974 Home Depot I'm good I'm about like
hike you have sundries here to play you
want to go to heck injures the hell out
of here I could just not around anymore
is that not national that shows near my
house where I grew up no idea what is
yeah I think that's just one store there
you
Everywhere's kind of Hechinger what
O'Reilly is in here Oh Oh Riley we
didn't pay for that in the mid nineties
1850s he became a well-known businessman
old Levi's in the city so he's killing
it killing it he was modest - it was
always like this is like a brand new
invention that people are like going ape
[ __ ] but he's things raking it oleic Ali
only LF only in the gold rush area but
make it hand over fist
yeah okay I'm Francisco on the outskirts
I wonder what happened like if a guy got
a train and went back east they'd be
like what the [ __ ] are you to Fanta blue
holy [ __ ] what's happening with you
undercard got your belt this load the
lower happy it was incredible oh my god
what is that yoke doing on you look at
the delightful yoke on you the way it
rides your hips you don't have to pull
those up to you oh not at all they just
hang on there yep
are they kosher absolutely and look at
he's talking in your Kosar yeah you know
I found these pants on the street where
nine restaurants were coached if one
wasn't I can't wear them I said beware
hold on I dropped under me yes yeah they
never cover why you would be street meat
no well you're just hungry number one
but if you're hungry and you go down
there I mean you got to make your like
as do I starve or stay kosher I mean if
it going down to where the restaurants
are you got anything you're going to a
restaurant anyway yeah but you're like
well why go all the way and what I could
you see this piece oh oh look beef I
look babe yeah great one one of the most
common phrases you hear on a notion is
resented some lamb hello are you guys
kosher you're not god damn it you
wouldn't probably know PMG middles oh
Happy Passover this meat on the floor is
the board letter puzzle for my father
yeah everybody better for those festive
holiday anyway there's new style of
working clothes it's so called overall
suit to the waist with super popular
gold diggers okay however a new problem
right now find new Italy this would be a
go to where do you put your ice cream
place
yeah we've both dabbled I think I never
really understood the 3x structure while
you do an introduction and then
something happens often active this is
like a little bit of a terror I decide
who will probably be when he went to
Cali for I think when he I think when he
when he actually made the pants I was
beginning act two when the guy like
that's when everything started to change
and then you get to a situation that you
don't think the hero would overcome then
your midpoint yeah right then you get
here all is lost
yeah and then when all is lost okay the
new problem was that the weight of the
gold carried by the gold diggers started
to tear the jeans oh there's too much
gold which is still a thing today and
not enough pant
yeah that's very true you know so so
there
so so they're making enough gold to put
in jeans at they're tearing jeans yeah
Angeles will slide a lot my chains at
that point it'd be like I got so much
gold that my pants are ripping in half
and I walk around naked holding my
[ __ ] gold oh the take your hat and
walk down to the bar and get a drink
like you're supposed to yeah yeah look
at the gold on the counter that's right
round for everybody and then it was like
whatever your pants are like you're
goddamn right what happened to my pants
Strauss - doesn't make good pan let's go
but in this Jews pants don't old goes
like east hand I spent three goals on
this pan for them how many gold my knees
to a deal
wait where's your scale scaling money
yeah we're gonna do chip this one give
me give me one chicken and change okay
anyway 1872 Levi received a letter from
Jacob Davis Oh Taylor of Baltic origin
to me was only delivering or delivering
denim okay regular customer okay so this
guy who's delivering Levi's denim Levi
is delivering it to delivering denim to
je vais let slavery of jeans are just
denim just down okay and Davis had his
idea oh [ __ ] is it pants no no go after
already done no okay he remember it was
like hey Levi how about we reinforce
both pockets and fasteners of the jeans
with the horse harness ribbit
why don't even know what that is you
deaf idiot here's where a horse harness
rivet you're standing up yeah see this
yeah that little button AHA that's oh
the little the little buttons on my
thighs had an actual purpose tour not
decorative look at this so they hold a
pocket in together they hold the pocket
together oh so it's like it's like more
so we got it we take it out it we're
taking it up a notch from thread and
we're putting some [ __ ] rivets up in
this [ __ ] and now way well I don't know
if that is a quote but now they had no
no that's what I said Dave I would never
I am so sorry okay so they but now they
have a button budgeted upon this [ __ ]
oh okay stay ready come on your bike oh
they're a little loose I got a little
loose
okay so he added the button yeah he
didn't have the money though for the 68
bucks for a patent okay oh oh that's a
lot for back man back then by the way
that seems like a huge amount yeah
that's pretty crazy man is right he's
doing well this Jakob Strauss know this
Jake oh oh yeah other guy they thought
seems like a shitload by the way now
that I think about it how bad Emmett's a
shitload yeah yeah how much the patent
now probably like a hundred fifty bucks
to go that much I can go get one yeah
you can get one yeah I hate yeah well my
friend needs work at the Patent Office
when I hear his favorite invention oh
yeah it's a because you all you have to
do to get a patent is not infringe on
another patent right that's it yeah or
add a clock or wheel to anything they'd
already done it's a great right yeah
yeah doesn't o'clock yeah yeah exactly
way with a patent and then the clock
microwave was a new patent I'll just
kind of get rich off my [ __ ] it'll piss
off denim my growing yeah favorite
invention was a method of inducing birth
through the use of centrifugal force oh
my god good it's not yeah you're
spinning the lady around until the baby
flies out that we got a centrifuge
tiller 5 G's rocks a baby out of a womb
her head to the middle there's a net on
the edge of her surrogate or Nexus that
isn't met no not a doctor spinning with
her that comes out sick I mean all right
so there's in the first unearthed Duluth
and fit nurse yeah hey I may so while
the lady's getting sick to the whole
thing's of throw-ups probably not a good
way to bring sorry not in a great
position on the baby story under duress
yeah and she's in a centrifuge stirrup
dog's baby just flies into the net and
then they stop the centrifuge and then
they go and grab the baby that was the
inventors idea good idea yeah I do you
grant you have to grant a patent it
doesn't matter how useful it is or who
will buy it it's just yeah you can just
make [ __ ] up yeah what I want to do
hobby that's why I'm doing a denim
microwave as you could get that in there
oh it feels like we have some disagree
okay
hahaha yeah do you think that inventor
was a man or a woman hmm
oh boy doctor said really tough my guy
is not white guy my guy's not a what my
God's not a white man you do say man I
would say that you're thinking it your
you don't think it's possible to woman
would it not so here we go so I can't
win I'll just carefully no because of me
why don't you Zeta incent why don't why
don't you think we're and cut this out
on May 20th 1873 the patent number one
three nine one two one was awarded to
Straus and Davis okay almost at once the
invention turned into massive profits
the new Pok so wait so is lead by a part
of this patent or say just I got
together they got to the NIH house no
Levi Strauss was his name Loeb Strauss
changed to Levi Strauss when he was the
other guy they Amos Oh Davis yeah it's
Justin Davis aiming with Jacob Davis
Jacob Davis so Jacob Davis has the idea
and Strauss patented yeah he was you get
the money to for the patent I don't what
do you think and you've also got James
what do you think but what joy what's
Davis is part of the deal it's my idea
is he getting he did they sent a good
boss they both got the patent both okay
it wasn't like Strauss okay so he only
what I'll cut you in oh he's fully like
a man I'm not a [ __ ] shyster okay
okay well for me Levi yeah I felt like
that's where what we got happened but
the guy went to the Big Mac got nothing
eventually he worked for MacDonald
MacDonald he's an employee you don't get
[ __ ] if you're an employee huh
should have waited and quit then take us
Gareth didn't get anything from this
podcast I tell him he does what are you
making money in this no okay see I can
be scared from it as we might rather go
around that idiot
no I was gonna say by the way I like
your new digs you start up with nicely
closely Thanks oh good test yeah all
right typical all motor profits that's
awesome yeah thank you
a load of these open a crown crown
you know got yourself in the Sun yeah
scratch up life's been good to Daddy
okay here's one problem though with
these rivets they were here they were on
the post pockets back pockets and middle
to hold it together grown mine right
that made it personal
yeah because Cowboys use it they sat
around a campfire oh god no no sing he's
saying that the buttons heat up yeah and
they burned their balls a lot of all oh
my god your balls really get burned yeah
it's a real thing to see if I'm making
this up yeah there's a real thing he
really thought he was burning balls yeah
they're sitting around campfires man
this metal is hot I'm close I mean close
enough tell you Larry yeah no I know
what do you get
I don't just I don't just like America
just split my legs when you go up to a
KO crotch person in iron heat up oh
that's nice Donna buttons yeah well they
said uh Indian legs after the kill team
Indians it's at Indian legs in honor of
their right they were like we got to be
sweet to the spirits if we've just taken
from this realm its crisscross
applesauce man lets it criss cross
applesauce
those are talked about that's what it's
Oh kids now and for when they first said
it I was like well what is that man I
think all right what we were doing was
so it's all made horribly my realizing
of terms you learned when you were like
six and you're just like Indian pearl
awful why no you know I'm one two three
four cachi yeah oh yeah I don't but I
don't catch the tiger by the tail but it
was yeah I remember that yeah people
cashed it not good yeah
good they changed I see so yeah I mean
it's not good the pump is bringing it
back you want to bring back all the old
Nursery Rhyme picking the new FBI
director so I removed the river from the
groin they're like this okay whatever if
you tell you if you tear your groin
that's on you but we don't want anybody
Burnham a dick if you tear your groin
that's on you I say you annoys James
but that still goes for today that's
still a pants thing if you buy a pants
as a gap to like and please sign his
papers get its way if you tear your
groin it's not honest brilliant here's
where you're sitting that's nothing to
do with us
they also remove the rivets in the back
pockets because those
scratching up chairs okay people were
sitting down really who knew that they
had a chair etiquette back then with all
the problems they have so now we're uilt
in general so now we're just back to the
front pocket front pocket this is just
beta testing really fine others right
shoe and like okay all right yeah well
this guy can chair yeah
mornin senator I would've had to pay to
replace some chairs and and cowboy
grinds yeah maybe they're dead me that
some lawsuits healed me a new chair yeah
and and leave us she'll psycho take it
up a Jacob how I got the scale some guy
just walks in and throws his ball sack
on the counter take a look at this bird
I like a new one and then he gets a
denim sack oh yeah oh suck yeah
replacements not bad where'd you get
your balls Dan oh these Levi's at the
same time the firm signature gold thread
appeared in the back pockets we have
that you know I know yeah I know you
mean yeah so why why was that were they
just action is that just a thing here's
why oh there's a reason yeah it's the
secret is in the Levi Strauss factory in
San Francisco which was destroyed by
fire in 1906 right turn that required
analytics so no one knows what that
means
that little swooped down and up you know
huh no one knows anymore it's just gone
it was gone
Levi knew and he didn't tell anybody was
knew he had the records in there they
didn't tell he didn't tell anybody I
fear was over well you know one new it's
all gone now it's over Andre goes again
mr. great Jean look at you listen to
great Jean mysteries hey we only have
one episode it was a massive revolt
really destroy the fabric of the country
so we stopped doing it
anybody guess as to why or is it just
gone I can't see any even guesses it
doesn't make any sense it's just like a
design I don't know alright what do you
think I mean there's some tie-in with
gold you know people are after goals and
there's some sort of gold tie and
perhaps no no and wearing Levi's here
brenton when you leave us I think it was
a Dave's Panther a label for [ __ ]
not really an amazing we're marking all
the going back AB negative eight
would you like the lamp answer this well
I guess what are my options
oh just the [ __ ] just your harmony off
but is near the pain is alright is
strong reinforced pockets for your
manual labor oh great ok yeah well you
get me down I'll be bookkeeping great
I don't even know what a pencil is yeah
a side note bookkeeper um and
bookkeeping only word in the English
language with three in a row double
letters wow this guy's dropping some
serious no I know
wait look okay well yeah wow that's
crazy yeah look at this you haven't told
me [ __ ] okay ke yeah yeah so this has
been wordplay with word okay the label
hae six has a label two horses pulling
on a pair of jeans
okay leather at first yeah right I'll
see you Matt yeah course is going to eat
a little extra means in the middle we
have xx yeah there which which represent
extra extra strength which I change to
501 later I don't want for no reason no
real reason that if I the XX was to
represent double straddle strength yeah
yeah one more NJ we know what you're
they change different yeah yeah yeah
this is the 70s fiber one appeared in
1890 1886 they had a leather thing with
the genes called xx 5 or 1 1894 four
years later and they change that name
from xx represented the extra extra
strength to find the ones are still
produced today they're the original
genes if you buy a pair of 501s but
saying the same style I want to change
yeah they have added a zipper for East
Coasters yeah cuz they could they
couldn't figure out no idea their dicks
faster it couldn't figure out the plug
bus easy does butterfly is I mean any if
you have button fly now you button fly
do you like it better I don't mind like
how do you get your dick you just rip it
yeah damnit ends with denim a sort of
[ __ ] fall party and then they're
popping up
maybe like you get it's just that the
tie up is worse yes I come on I got a
button my crotch you know what me no
like real accidents like painful
accidents
well Ilic if i'm a campfire what have
you done man I haven't done that Ivan
I've never stepped out of my oh man once
I had all I wanted to do it yeah but not
and I'm now much older I don't do that I
had one once where I thought I was gonna
have to like call 911
I was really yeah yeah it's amazing I
had to go to work and I was just like
dude did a job God what do we call the
zipper teeth oh because it feels like a
bite I did that with the button fly much
harder that is much harder oh boy to
sharpen one of the button Oh God
actually not really very big I'm not
getting out of this one it is okay uh
his later years Levi Strauss is a
millionaire yeah huge buck yeah they're
King philanthropists oh yeah an honored
citizen San Francisco okay
sponsor a shelter for Jewish orphans
that side okay Dave I don't think it's
time to be a player
yeah but why but why yours yeah why not
just all working I don't know man Jews
have this weird thing don't care
themselves yeah Jews have a brotherhood
I know but just take care of all the
orphans I mean I agree with you why not
just have orphaned they're too many
maybe okay yeah what seems like in my
greatest also like you just want to take
care of the black in the the way my
rabbi said it cuz we're not Jews and all
other Church interest other Jews
you can charge interest to non-jews and
uh Rashi the commentator would say why
is that do you think non-jews are worse
than them and they go no it's not that
is worse the Jews your brothers so
obviously charge interest that's how you
make money on money but to your brother
you extend in the courtesy I'm going
interest-free well Wow Scott really and
it's not everything yeah so that's what
I'm really that's why we don't ya that's
why the other baby you bench anyway
that's why the other babies laying the
gutter and die you know but the Crown
Heights riots
now oh yeah so this happened the same
thing there's a Jewish ambulance service
in Crown Heights okay Roma Jews for Jews
whatever there was a car that hit two
kids black kid Jewish kid
now yeah and you know 9/11 was a joke so
they didn't get there for a while and
before they got there at the Jewish
neighborhood showed up and they picked
up the Jewish kid off they went and they
left the black kids to die
I haven't him yeah it was a good time
Lord and black people I think they said
like all right well what are we doing
wrong I guess that's fair and we have to
get our own we get a black ambulance did
not work out those Jews and they're
pretty madam yeah that's where they were
man I don't know why I get it I think if
you think about it for a minute you
could see their son yeah oh yeah well
thankfully awful thankfully those days
are behind us and not and everything has
changed now absolutely there will be a
time when there will be like regulars oh
wow yeah it's coming but you
libertarians want yeah yeah they want
like do it yourself if you want to do it
then yeah I'm into it yeah rich people
will get better every boat service poor
people will get whatever their kind be
like the Internet what a minute what's
they do what's they get through net
neutrality another trail ever no yeah
yeah you could pay for more yeah I'm on
the OP not orality really yeah I want to
be told what I should watch them
download American corporation should
tell me like it oh god what kind of corn
do I get to watch that's it that
honestly would be the one reason why
people wouldn't stand yeah they'd be
like oh I didn't expect this okay all
right get the picket sign no way what is
this girl on girl only no no I need
deviant shake come on where's the snail
coming out of a join us well I root for
the same thing to be honest yeah yeah
guy with the sign let me see Sam come on
Ted don't help dick I think you're wrong
come on George no no totality to put
that out this is Pacific he also funded
for non-jews he uh that was a fun for a
new rail line San Francisco oh hey hi
yeah that's also going to help him yeah
any hits yeah yeah yeah sure
they also funded 28 grants at Berkeley
28 28 different grants all right that's
what I remember servers like yeah I
think plater a green day he's one of
those grants I believe created yeah that
was yeah yeah that guy riding a bathroom
she's real history zoom to dr. power
that is a curse Green Day tired oh yeah
uh finally agreed a fax was saving here
Anna re and our Erin on the ones the
Jews yeah boy he died September 26 1900
son-of-a-bitch hey never married I
brought kids let's still know why okay
you think Amelia I was married to the
genes he's gay maybe he's got a gay he's
gay guy back in those that's right back
in those days if you're not getting
married you're it's because you're
you're like well I could get married to
have a fake wife or I'll just be a
bachelor gentlemen yeah well then well
you don't see later they married people
they didn't like back then they're like
well just do this it was okay marriage
might have been with a right way friend
for forever
yeah and he literally was a rich guy who
hung out with gold diggers put a sound
today's term could have found ya a what
yeah oh yeah oh yeah I don't know it
feels like they're all after me for the
money or maybe in UVs renders houses
just surrounded by jewish orphans look
at all the boys I have no time for women
the Prabhu boy with my boys hold out
your dishes boys porridge time who's gay
right that's right doctor you know
usually when you go back and look at the
people either they were super weird but
he doesn't sound that weird usually the
super weird ones but then often it's
just because they're like no I like
dudes and I can't marry dude so I'm
gonna just cruise I will tell you that
the BTK killer was a Cub Scout leader
and a pat not past a but a leader of his
Lutheran Church of course he was dead
but he wasn't gay I mean he had other
[ __ ] here's some other stuff his mother
[ __ ] on I had a kid right desires yeah
he had a couple kids yes Brendon Killman
there's a BTK scholarship and that's
yeah Randall er yeah actually I was
doing the research for that I'm like
this is too gruesome yeah you're right
this way they all say yeah well you guys
are Plato's is way better but this was
like those if I can be funny in any way
and then in any splitter head over hey
why don't you bring up the genes one
action it is lifetime genes were only
one in California really only one
California's never made a little bit
over the mountains he was probably shown
so many that he was just like I can only
make as many as I can make I'm it's like
in and out survive for a long time just
don't Yallah for Nia
yeah it's still crazy yeah but it's just
different time so yeah and if there's no
railroad yet yeah then how are you
getting them over then you got to put
them on a [ __ ] what I don't so you're
right it's like now the transfer of like
knowledge is so quick and simple
whereas then you just see a guy be like
what the hell I die is gone yeah yeah we
had I mean the idea of being famous on
the east coast or west coast have gone
now you're famous Nia's coast you're
just you're famous right I've heard
right here on the Wesker yeah but back
then people like do you hear about jeans
no well dude no what what were they well
I don't I don't know much funny said
some are they where they call the what
were they call back then they weren't
called jeans around when they called
Diggory India yes
do your legs degree do the word no
didgeridoo if it did you redo no that's
a no that's a no I'm done read Unger
Hungary Tigers that was the word I'm
looking for
didn't didn't say that ever a dating a
dumb green other three places I look
that's what these now I mean look he
look three places in the world dungarees
where did wooden genes come up like how
are his ass oh yeah you're the guy who
was on top of this hole what a may
become gene I mean I was a b-plus
student so I did b-plus research give it
you went to fashion school better than
to go to the FI - yeah are you looking
up dungarees you'd look I'm done right
when did jeans first the word jeans once
it Linney ology is that the word her my
I had a Mike good genealogy it's just
another way allergy cream yeah hungry
hey let us win reacting to this thanks
man shall oppose doctor to fabric jeans
of the fabric who knew
that's right used in England from 1605
to 16 15 yeah 1605 to 16 15 what James
that's what it says that it was a fabric
oh but I guess now now it's a subset of
denim what with subsets it typically
refers to the most common style of blue
denim denim so there you go
I'm I'm glad I brought this up yeah yeah
it said fun anyways love most of us six
million dollars to his nephews okay the
rest of the terrible needs of both
Jewish and Christian organization wait
there we go so we're his bro his
brothers dead then because he has
nephews yeah oh right right so he had
you been in touch with them but we just
don't know anything about we don't know
at the record you Lesage huh yeah I
usually watch it was wrought in darkened
yeah he's not an important one he didn't
do [ __ ] he might have felt bad for like
I'm rich my nephews are still selling
dry goods like Schmucks in New York
right how the textiles coming yeah
you're coming back with his gold filled
denim jeans in every guy should come to
California with me when I asked you to
us all right [ __ ] on a rug no none of
these Jewish orphans yes in the Great
Depression Levi's company Levi Strauss
and company started marketing them
across the country as it affordable and
durable oracles clothing
oh so it's a cheap pant once it started
with advertising then it became like a
thang cheap an okay detected people from
dirt and yeah and they left they last a
[ __ ] a while cause the first pan easy to
water to there's another thing you just
run water through them and they're clean
well I've liked him since they got rid
of the buttons they're the penis that
was an issue for me that was a problem
that's what I watch a campfire guy
everyone knows me knows where the
campfire guy like are you how are you
well then you have guys coming over to
the campfire bottomless just like sorry
gentlemen I've been asking her a buckle
to be put in the groin full buckle full
buckle and then I want to get really
close to that fire yeah you know I mean
I get that buckle nice and hot yes some
people were brands on there so they
would like really yeah here in Iraq
that's I'm talking letter or something a
scarlet letter another night is there
time I'm sorry
why is on my team they be on my balls
I'm not a weirdo it's hard to find you
labeled there was a wide advertising
campaign and after the Second World War
characters of westerns wearing jeans oh
that was low right yeah all over the
world wait till the Marlboro Man comes
in yeah okay when all the night all over
the world that's what had happened East
Coasters New Yorkers especially couldn't
handle the button flies like what it
really what is this and that's when they
start putting the flies away I live in
there [ __ ] idiots yeah New York City
yeah I know hey there's the country so
New York and then it always always ended
horribly yeah it was like four minutes
away from a murder
it was always never good I'm guy you
brought New York City cells it was
attached to a truck while guys like
let's kill him yeah yeah come on guys
I'm alone hi I'm Jen I'm just enjoying
my break salsa I'm just enjoying my
salsa we could use your salsa we brought
it shut up shut up and get dried to
death put the gun in him before they had
like shooting some of the players like
yeah I need you to eat this left
literally eat it and then he'll guys I'm
a nominee for this inside of you oh boy
this takes forever um interesting fact
Levi Strauss old Loeb never wore a pair
of Levi's himself shut the [ __ ] up
not once how is that possible he was a
businessman and jeans are for laborers
Wow
really yeah really so there's some
classes and [ __ ] going on here now
maybe he's like I don't need to like I'm
totally on board now I'm like it wasn't
oh I hate jeans not on my knees
chiseling oh I hate me I hate jeans this
I wonder if he thought because of the
way things worked if if wealthy people
started wearing him then
they might become for the wealthy
instead of for the worker or something
it's just weird that he would be like
well that's for the poor I'm in are
aware of tool belt well not anymore
I mean I did that act for a couple years
where you are hard to get my pick up are
you sure that's the problem
sorry kept we forgot a screwdriver on
accident
damnit isn't working I'm developed I
mean it makes me not like him as much
really yeah I don't think it was classic
my think was just like why would I up I
clean it a little bit yeah I mean I mean
really cool yeah if he's not an actual
worker which is they're marketed for I
get it a little bit
don't look at me like that Dave I'm not
but it's okay to not like him I know you
don't like a lot of juice yeah call them
I just gotta find one reason Eddie ever
column June's
go maybe he tried probably trying that
at one point something just like now in
the year 2000 in the small German city
of botton Heim here we go north of
Bavaria the small blue house we'll leave
I grew up a museum opened up oh [ __ ]
Museum for the most famous trousers in
the history of the world Levi's Levi's
Museum yeah today an adult home how
great is that Museum I've not been there
but now I'm going to go I'll get my
brother live near there I'm like this I
believe is it true he does live in that
goes backwards in like Zurich and
Germany and will for sure go I realize
now I'm gonna go for it with him yeah
yeah I like small museums that's a small
one yeah with a site I'm gonna walk
again there's a pair of pants and it in
a Chester drawer it's just a cow hey
wait a minute this is [ __ ] yeah I'll
take them I'll take them but this is
[ __ ] I really expected something
else gap the oldest-known trousers I'm
remembering I didn't write down or from
like 1872 found in a gold mine in Nevada
when I wanted abandon there they were
holding up with with rubber gloves to
like protect them really I blasted there
in the jeans
yeah she's certain the Levi's company
right now thinking I think's are you
gonna outlive mankind yeah terrible man
the durable pan oh [ __ ] around
well when you go to the museum you got a
you know where to buy some jeans
yeah it's gonna suck yeah I'm shaking
there's not a job
booting up Church in Scripture so no
button crotch was yeah no tape buttons
yeah also something I didn't say the the
little tag this is Levi's that red tag
yeah added to show that they were
different from imposters which started
cropping up around
I'm like these have attitude together
really they could they not hadn't
pounded him I don't know how I think is
about only good for a hundred years or
something know it back then it was not
even that it was really short a 15-7 I
think I work from your hat you saw for
seven years I think back then you could
renew like once or twice and then you're
done
what now now it's forever and forever no
now you can just keep you can just keep
keeper nice you know you can keep the
renewing [ __ ] and they have little ways
to get around it but like you know tons
of patents should have run out but they
keep going especially companies like
Disney and stuff right ed enough they're
like how weird like it's like with
pharmaceutical companies they'll create
a drug and then they'll be like well the
oh the pill is small and orange and then
they'll patent that that's why pills
aren't right all these different shapes
and colors because there's a patent that
[ __ ] really and enables them to extend
it and yeah it's garbage
that's garbage usually well that's
weighted only by staying with her but
what's even that was a good great that's
really good this is the first time we've
had someone come on and read one really
yeah yeah you didn't really do it with
guess well we know this is the first
time we've had a guest on an on live one
reality we've only done live one so it's
a one you do the live ones how did you
do a lot of live ones to Dave will read
it to me in someone else yes
yeah they were like why don't we do it
word you prepare and I was like more
yeah that's good though man what are we
good yeah now it's a special episode
yeah now it's a very special episode so
plug I make no special yeah go ahead
my double special double negative yeah
there's on Netflix right now July 18th
and watch it in two parts or in one
sitting wherever you want to do it Ari
Shaffir
called children and adulthood two
different sides of it Richie where'd you
take the shuttle in Austin Texas at cap
city comedy club alright built in a new
stage comes a stuff with so ugly those
pipes great yeah I got a lot of money on
like maybe why you shooting that I
should get like you're spending so much
money right I didn't think of this okay
I get it not smart well go and watch Ari
special on Netflix we also have a
podcast called are you super skeptic
tank as well as punch drunk as a puncher
sports I film here with Aaron and you
see my butthole how many times there
many many times baker's dozen if not the
pictures both on some nine tonight so I
put in it
episodes not as gross especially so uh
and then doing anything else just fire
bloody night absurdity I would leave
with re-scope how long I got to write a
book well it's you know it's kind of
like it's because it's off of stories
that we already did on the podcast yeah
wasn't the host I mean it wasn't easy
because we had to condense them down and
then you know I mean in general a book
takes a good amount of work just because
there's a lot of notes and there's a lot
of you know numbers you got to hit and
getting the art and all that [ __ ] and
researching and tightening them up and
try to make them funny you know I
thought that I thought it was so cool it
goes fast super weird look it's weird I
get my mom a copy the other day and I
think she was so like I just never had
any idea you would be near writing you
don't know smart you understand you
almost fell out of high school do you
understand my amazement code among peers
know me okay well my stupid boy did you
not one typo is it stupid
[Laughter]
oh yeah his mom oh you know that was
only someone's in the business some was
in the book business now she's just
becoming a pauper also most common story
books always like memoirs oh yeah yeah
yeah was i standing at what Stanhope
wrote a book I was like first I'm gonna
start making this joke to everyone who
writes a book but except you guys this
is always a memory like is there a novel
yeah he's like no it's not a novel oh
all right well great well thank you
coming on oh yeah Victor I'm appreciated
and Dave take care bye-bye nice one
curse
I'll be sidecars